[Applauso]
[Musica]
Immagina che nel tuo ultimo giorno di
vita la persona che sei incontra la
persona che saresti potuto diventare
pensando al tuo futuro
se fossi più sicuro o sicura di te che
cosa faresti che oggi non fai
chi saresti che oggi non sei
Lo sai che c'è qualcosa in te che ti
chiama un futuro diverso si soltanto
fossi più sicuri di te
oggi voglio offrire tre chiavi per
aprire le porte al futuro che sogni e
sono delle chiavi che ho imparato a
usare in questi ultimi anni e che uso
tuttora per costruire la vita che sogno
quali sono
la prima chiave è vivere con integrità
cioè
tu sai oggi cosa ritieni importante e
giusto benissimo quanto ti impegni a
metterlo in pratica Quanto fai ciò che è
giusto e invece di ciò che è facile
Basta poco Diciamo che un tuo valore sia
la gentilezza
aiuti la signora che ha esagerato con la
spesa ad arrivare con i suoi sacchetti
fino al tram
porti pazienza con la macchina lenta
davanti a te quando torni a casa la sera
o semplicemente regali un sorriso a chi
non conosci se lo hai mai fatto sai che
è pura magia e questi piccoli gesti
concreti alzano la tua autostima perché
se non stimi come ti stai comportando
Prima di tutto con te stesso e poi anche
con gli altri Allora una bassa autostima
non è altro che buon senso più fai ciò
che ritieni giusto invece di ciò che è
facile più alti la tua autostima e più
diventi sicuro di te
perché ti piace talmente tanto che
importa sempre meno cosa pensano gli
altri di te
la seconda chiave è fare le cose che non
hai nessuna voglia di fare le cose che
ti aiutano a costruire il tuo futuro
esempio è attività sportiva per
mantenerti il format tutti sappiamo che
ci fa bene e magari tu sei una di quelle
persone che non vedono l'ora di sudare
Ecco io no Io mi alleno la mattina ma
non ho mai voglia anzi io pagherete che
tu a misurare per farlo al posto mio
e magari per te non è lo sport magari
per te studiare
e tenere in ordine casa tua
risparmiare e frequentare un corso di
formazione o andare a dormire prima
Cosa succede quando con costanza fai le
cose che non vuoi fare
persistere scalare quel muro di
resistenza al giorno dopo giorno non
solo ti fa diventare più bravo in quelle
che fai ti rende più forte anche
mentalmente e alla fine è questa l'unica
differenza fra chi ottiene risultati e
si costruisce la vita che vuole e chi no
fare le cose che non hai voglia di fare
ti fa acquisire di te una sicurezza
pazzesca perché sai scalare i muri
e la terza chiave è quella più potente
fai della paura tua amica
vi svelo un segreto che in pochi
sembrano conoscere la persona impavida
quelle che non ha paura di nulla
non esiste il nostro cervello è
predisposto a farci venire paura a dare
l'allarme ogni volta che vuoi cambiare
lo status quo
Anzi oggi sappiamo che abbiamo ben tre
cervelli una rete neuronale complessa il
primo cervello è quello nella testa
eppure lui è suddiviso in tre parti
principali abbiamo il sistema la il
cervello rettile per il tuo senso di
sicurezza E l'istinto di attacco e fuga
abbiamo il sistema limbico per le tue
emozioni e la tua motivazione e la
neocorteccia molto ben sviluppata negli
esseri umani
per il tuo pensiero logico e queste tre
parti lavorano un po' in amore
indipendente e un po' insieme
perché è utile saperlo perché se vuoi
andare oltre la paura devi andare in
ordine prima rassicurati va Tutto bene
Sei al sicuro poi aggiungi le tue
emozioni più belle l'entusiasmo la gioia
la curiosità
e solo dopo sei pronto veramente a
pensare in modo logico
il secondo cervello è nel cuore la neoru
cardiologia è il terzo nella pancia la
gastro- neurologia
tu lo sapevi che il cuore manda più
informazioni al cervello di quante ne
riceve Beh sappiamo che a volte il cuore
la pensa diversamente dalla testa e sono
di quattro tipi diversi sono impulsi
nervosi
ormoni
onde create dal flusso di sangue e dalla
sua pressione e
impulsi elettromagnetici
Infatti il campo elettromagnetico del
cuore è ben 5000 volte più forte di
quello del cervello
e il cuore della pancia
abbiamo oltre 500 milioni di neuroni
nell'intestino ed è dotato di plasticità
cioè sa imparare può cambiare
comportamento
e poi il 90% della serotonina il nostro
ormone del buon umore
immettate la dopamina il nostro ormone
della felicità vengono prodotte proprio
nell'intestino
e ogni volta che vuoi fare una cosa
nuova che non hai mai fatto prima vuoi
fare di più di una cosa che ti avvicina
al tuo futuro oppure di punirne un'altra
che ti frena i tuoi tre cervelli si
fanno prendere dalla paura e ti dicono
non farlo potrebbe essere pericoloso
E va bene così perché da sempre il loro
unico scopo principale non è la tua
felicità Mi dispiace E neanche il tuo
successo è la tua sopravvivenza fisica
emotiva e mentale a loro piace lo status
quo piace tenerti là dove sei oggi e
farti continuare sulla stessa strada
nella stessa direzione alla stessa
velocità
Ma quando osi Faro un passo oltre
succede della Magia perché ogni volta
che scegli di fare questo passo nuovo
tu cresci la paura diminuisce E tu
diventi più sicuro di te fino a fare Il
passo successivo che ti spaventa E
quello dopo ancora diventando più sicuro
con ogni passo e la cosa più bella è che
questa sicurezza in te che acquisisci
rimane Tua per sempre
un conto è fare le cose che ti
spaventano quando hai poca scelta un
conto è scegliere esperienze che ti
fanno paura per costruire il tuo futuro
devi fare apposta
fai della paura tua amica sarà sempre
una tua compagna di viaggio Ma mettila
sul sedile dietro al volante ci stai tu
a decidere la direzione e la velocità
e se oggi quando pensi al tuo futuro non
ti viene paura
e anche un po' il tuo sogno è troppo
piccolo per spalancare le porta al tuo
futuro usa le tre chiavi fai ciò che
ritieni giusto invece di ciò che è
facile scala quel muro di resistenza E
fai le cose che non hai voglia di fare e
poi la paura ti faccio Un'ultima domanda
importante
qual è una cosa che ti spaventa da
morire ma che farebbe la differenza per
il tuo futuro
fai il primo passo questa settimana solo
il primo
e quando hai paura Ricorda che la
sicurezza viene dall'agire con testa
cuore e pancia e l'unico antidoto alla
paura è l'azione
[Applauso]